what a wonderful surprise
writing clank rift apart is a brand new
standalone adventure featuring our
heroes many years in the past beyond the
events of 2013's into the nexus with our
heroes getting celebrated for a lifetime
of galaxy saving adventures clank is
planning to surprise ratchet with a
fixed dimensionator potentially
reuniting him with the rest of the long
boxes unfortunately the untimely arrival
of dr nefarious messes things up
separating our heroes in a strange new
dimension
now they will need to figure out how to
find one another return home and correct
the damage that has been done to the
fabric of space time before everything
is destroyed
insomniac is aiming to take what folks
love about the franchise and turn it up
to 11. exciting gameplay is driven by
character motivation and the narrative
extends out of cutscenes and interplay
itself
every planet has its own self-contained
unique story and all of the characters
have full lives and personalities to
discover
plus there's plenty of humor for
everyone
players will have the opportunity to see
some familiar faces from previous
entries in the franchise and also
experience an entirely new dimensional
version of some of the cast for example
skin mcmarx is a famous hoverboard
champion and is a laid-back dude in the
normal dimension
in this alternate universe he's better
known as fent a member of the resistance
fighting against emperor nefarious's
evil regime perhaps most exciting of all
we are introduced to rivet she is an
entirely new character with her own
distinct personality and a lot of
history in this unusual dimension rivet
unlike ratchet has been on her own her
entire life
she never had a best friend to help her
through her struggles no one to
celebrate her wins with and no one to
turn to in life's darkest moments
in insomnic's own words river is such an
important character to so many of us and
our goal was to do her justice
all the departments rallied around her
and we believe that we've created a new
hero that all players can look up to
ratchet and clank is a franchise that is
known for its crazy guns when working on
weapons the team tries to evaluate them
around 3 x's how spectacular is this
weapon to use
does this weapon fulfill a unique
strategic niche in combat and how
humorous or unique is this weapon
looking at the negatron collider the
topiary sprinkler and all the other
surprises that await they've pretty much
done a banged up job from utilizing the
dual sensor's adaptive triggers to an
increased focus on visual and sound
design combat has never felt more
immersive and amazing whether you're
playing as ratchet rivet or clank the
power of the ps5 is evident
dimensional riffs lets you instantly
teleport between locations and even
worlds the visual fidelity in the
different set pieces are jaw droppingly
gorgeous and the 3d audio and the dual
sense allows for more dimensions turning
the pun to the experience
like all ps5 games loading is done in an
instant which allows insomniac games to
build the different dimensions of worlds
and have players jumping between them
for strategic and gameplay purposes
some of our worlds are even based around
this mechanic entirely more importantly
it looks like other fun because
streaming is so fast the game only needs
to load the content that you need right
at the moment for textures or objects
behind you the game will stream them out
if you turn the camera around it will
stream them back in all of these means
that insomnia can get a much higher
density of art content in all different
corners of the world
players will be treated to visual
spectacles on every planet they arrive
on
civilians and enemies are smarter and
more responsive than ever because of the
power of the ps5
in just a short month's time you will
finally be ready to enter the new
dimensions brought to you by wretched
and clank rift apart be sure to check
out our preview of the game as well as
an in-depth interview with creative
director marcus smith link's in
description below
for all things geeky and dimension
warping stay tuned to geek culture
if you're broken so am i and i think
we're pretty awesome
do you have any ideas because i'm having
a hard time thinking while running away
from a giant homicidal robot i am
working on it
mine's collapsed
wisdom
i may have an idea i'm all ears
i am broken
i cannot fix
oh dear